it is important that our SMEs and
startups face no purveyors to scale up
and enter new markets in the future by
mere 2018 we should adopt the electronic
communication code and clarify state aid
rules for the compensation of current
users of the necessary spectrum for 5g
by me 2019 we should have technical
decisions to ensure that necessary
spectrum for the 5g will be available by
the end of 2020 there should be at least
one city in each member state with 5g
connectivity by 2022 the 700 megahertz
band is available in all Member States
the final roll out of the Falchi network
is planned by the year 2025 when I wish
to have the 5g network available at
least in all major cities and transport
roads across the entire you we achieved
a channeler approach on the product
regulation my team has worked hard to
ensure that regulators of electronic
communication sector are able to
cooperate efficiently and I am happy
that the member state showed strong
consensus today we also took note on the
core progress made on a privacy
regulation the complexity of the
questions illustrates the importance of
the file sucrose Akiba Clairmont
reckoning Volante booty i mean position
Kamino can say Ivana fan Delaney Seaton
second opera man Nia no transition Dava
Anika avec la paloma rupiah de sylheti
DeMille de suite